hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Gotham episode 1 video they're
rolling hard on Batman villains
including a lot of Suicide Squad
villains so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet I think
the show's already a lot better than it
was last season okay so we got a whole
bunch of new Batman villains that are on
Gotham even some Suicide Squad
characters and let's just start at the
top so we'll say you know number 10 WTF
Killer Croc is in Gotham now the way
they're explaining this version of
Killer Croc is that he has not fully
become the Killer Croc that you just got
done seeing in the Suicide Squad movie
so I'm expecting the makeup to evolve
like if you think he looks kind of weird
like hey this doesn't look like Killer
Croc that's just because he has not
fully become Killer Croc yet so number 9
WTF they're swapping Lee for Valerie
Vale who is kind of like the show's
version of Vicki Bale everybody probably
got that even if it's been a long time
since you've seen a Batman story or a
movie with the Vicki Vale character in
fact they actually went for a Michael
Keaton Batman movie Easter Egg when in
that movie Vicki Vale is in the
newspaper headquarters talking about the
Batman but nobody knows who he is and
they make the joke about him being a
vampire who sucks people's blood so
Valerie Vale on the TV show gets the
shot of the vampire hanging out the
window so this is kind of like a meta
Easter Egg for the Michael Keaton Batman
Vicki Vale storyline but this person
here on the TV show just to be clear is
Valerie Vale played by Jamie Chung and I
will say far and away she has way more
chemistry with Gordon like you kind of
see what they're doing they're swapping
her character for Lee's character who's
like off in the suburbs somewhere
hanging out with this dude I totally
love Morena Baccarin but I feel like the
way they were using her on the show just
wasn't that great so Valerie Vale
already seems like a vast improvement
just the way they're using her on the
show in the way that they're tying all
the characters together like you have
Valerie Vale the news reporter doing
what normal news reporters would do
tracking down a story building leads
Catwoman is the big lead for her story
but Gordon comes to Miss Peabody's
separately through Bullock so you have
all these different characters
interacting in separate ways but at the
same time converging at the same point
of the episode so the way they built the
episode out the way they
plotted it was actually really good I'd
say this guy's a pretty good
approximation of TV show man-bat but
there were vampire versions of a lot of
characters in the Batman universe even
Batman himself there was a vampire
Batman for a little while so I say this
guy's closer to man bad because of the
actual physical wings be pretty cool
that they're doing him he's pretty far
out there in terms of characters the
next one enter the penguin and you have
another Easter Egg for the Danny DeVito
penguin you know more Michael Keaton
Batman callbacks so a lot of the TV show
is inspired by Tim Burton's version of
Batman but if you remember Danny
DeVito's version of the penguin he tried
to do some politicking like he tried to
present himself as this candidate for
mayor hey I'm this wonderful upstanding
member of the community just trying to
look out for everyone's welfare and TV
show penguin is doing the exact same
thing like trying to present himself as
this upstanding member of the community
look all these monsters are loose you
should be scared of them we need to get
rid of them and somebody was in charge
like he tries to throw fish mooney under
the bus so he's trying to use the threat
of the monsters in the police to take
control of the city again
for number seven day drunk Gordon day
drunk bullet couple big changes inside
the police department so if you didn't
know Jim is not on the police force
anymore he's working as a bounty hunter
the mayor's put out bounties for all the
different monsters and thanks to the
Valerie Vail quote we know there's
between twenty and thirty monsters loose
so like Gordon can make a lot of money
by bringing them in so that's what
they're going to have him do this season
just because it allows them to have a
little more fun with the character and
because it allows Ben McKenzie to play
Gordon in a more fun way and he pretty
much tells that to Bullock when he's
explaining why he isn't come back to the
police force I can drink whenever I want
I can come and go when I want and then
Bullock's like hey I can drink whatever
I want to to it just like takes a swig
that was probably one of the funniest
moments in the episode getting day drunk
at the police station
but speaking of getting drunk number six
wTF is the sirens Club it's a very not
subtle reference to Gotham City sirens
which is where you arrive at Harley
Quinn Catwoman who's hanging out at the
bar too and then eventually poison ivy
who's turning into like this sexy
version of the character who will prey
on men so eventually she's going to turn
up at this nightclub so I would expect
to see a lot of
comic book Gotham City sirens stuff
happening on the TV show but if there
was any confusion
Barbara Vil said you know number five
WTF Barbara is the TV show's version of
Harley Quinn so what they said about the
character in the past is is that they
were going to do her but then more
recently when they were at comic-con
people were asking them again and they
said well she might already be on the
show
we just haven't put the costume on her
yet like she hasn't become the Harlequin
character fully yet so instantly I was
like oh yeah that's probably Barbara who
is the only batshit crazy female
character who vaguely resembles Harley
Quinn in the comics Oh Barbara right
away she even had brief moments with
Jerome who was kind of like the TV's
version of the Joker and they did say
that Jerome is coming back so number
four WTF we will have Harley Quinn Joker
stuff happening maybe in the second half
of the season which I know like number
four WTF a lot of people wondering who
is this character is this Lincoln March
from the comics is this Thomas Wayne jr.
is he going to turn into Talent so
here's what I think about this because
they haven't really said anything about
it they just been calling him
doppelganger Bruce in there are two big
characters in the comics who both look
like Bruce and try to take his place
one is Lincoln March that was part of a
court of owls storyline they're doing
court of owls on the TV show so I'll
explain his backstory in a second but
the other character is Thomas Eliot
whose hush in the comics so right now
I'm leaning closer to Lincoln March just
because of all the overlap with court of
owls in the way Lincoln marches
backstory works in the comics basically
the gist is is that Lincoln March tells
Batman that he is Thomas Wayne jr.
secretly the son of Bruce's parents the
older son like the first son that they
had who was left in an orphanage and
then taken in by the court of owls and
groomed to eventually take Bruce's place
so it kind of seemed because Indian Hill
is where this doppelganger came from
seems like the court of owls may have
had something to do with his creation
and it seems like they are grooming him
to take Bruce's place so that they can
fully control Wayne Enterprises because
Bruce had that scene at the end where
he's like I know that there are members
of a shadowy organization in this room I
want a meeting with them and then he
walks out he's basically
telling the board that he knows that the
court of Alice has a plant and he wants
to communicate with them so you guys can
let me know in the comments but I really
do I feel like this character even if
they change a bunch of comic book stuff
is going to be the Lincoln March
character my number three was that last
seen at the sirens where they just all
have that funny moment we're like okay
this is all stupid
butch very clearly wants to get in with
Tabitha again sent this dude after us so
they just slice them up and penguin just
shoots them finishes him off and walks
off just like grumbling to himself a
fine run your club do whatever I just
think it's a good example of
well-written Batman humor because Batman
stories typically involved like really
dark people so as you would expect a lot
of the jokes rely on really big WTF
twists so they're funny but they usually
involve someone dying or getting hit by
a bus so number two is the end of young
poison ivy and maybe some of you didn't
know that they were bringing an adult
poison ivy on the show
they've been hyping her up for the last
couple of months so there was a lot of
question as to how they were going to
transform young poison ivy into adult
poison ivy was she going to go into a
chrysalis was there going to be some
sort of metahuman explanation for it so
I'm guessing the next time we see her
she'll be like climbing out of the water
like wherever the sewer ended up dumping
her and she'll be an adult but finally
number one the talent comes for Bruce
captures him brings him before the court
of owls as he requested he wanted an
audience he got it so as with all things
you always expect Batman to win so
ultimately yeah Bruce will take down the
court of owls but for now they are a
very powerful shadow organization and
he's a little kid doesn't know anything
about them so while fish Mooney is
definitely a villain during the season
the real villain like the true villains
this season are the court of owls let me
know in the comments like what did you
guys think about the episode do you like
that they're doing so much more comic
book stuff it definitely felt like a
real comic book story so I think the
show's done a lot of really good course
correcting I like the direction that
it's headed so I don't know if I'm going
to do videos for it every single week
I'll definitely do an episode 2 video
just because there's there's nothing
else that's going to be on Monday
there's no schedule conflict but
eventually Supergirl will be on Monday
nights at the exact same time I'm going
to do a Supergirl episode one video so
I'll just try to remind everyone how the
schedules changing as we go along but I
am still doing the deed
to give away all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video is just for the flash
season 2 on blu-ray and what's going to
happen is is like the flash isn't back
for another week or so but they'll
probably be a new trailer tomorrow so
I'll do video for that if it posts
there's probably going to be a lot more
DC TV show stuff happening in the next
couple of weeks just because all the TV
shows are coming back but agents of
shield is also premiering tomorrow so
just heads up I will be doing a video
for that tomorrow night while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for the big Supergirl season two
Superman trailer and you can click here
for my last big flash trailer video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you